SPEAK TO AVENATTI'S ASSAULT ON
DEMOCRAT ITS CREDIBILITY IS THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
SINCE TRUMP ENTERED HIS RUN FOR
THE PRESIDENCY IN 2016,
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR MEDIA
SYCOPHANTS HAVE BEEN ON AN
ABSOLUTE MISSION TO NOT JUST
DEFEAT HIM BUT TO DESTROY HIM.
AND ALL THOSE AROUND HIM AS WEL
WELL.
THEY ARE ALSO BLINDED BY THEIR
HATRED OF ALL THINGS TRUMP SO
MUCH SO THAT THEY HAVE HITCHED
THEIR POLITICAL WAGONS TO A CAST
OF RADICAL UNSAVORY CHARACTERS
THAT LOOKS LIKE A REUNION OF THE
SUICIDE SQUAD.
ENTER MICHAEL AVENATTI.
A TWO BIT TAX CHEAT AND
CELEBRITY ATTORNEY REBORN AS
CRUSADING LAWYER TO PORN STAR
TRUMP ACCUSER STORMY DANIELS.
>> THE PRESIDENT TRUSTED
MR. COHEN AS HIS FIXER FOR
YEARS.
HE TRUSTED HIM WITH HIS
INNERMOST SECRETS AND I THINK
THAT THE CHICKENS ARE ABOUT TO
COME HOME TO ROOST.
>> Laura: THEY ARE COMING HOME
TO ROOST, ALL RIGHT.
AS A BATTERING RAM AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP AND LATER HIS SUPER
IMPORTANT ON MANY BRETT
KAVANAUGH, AVENATTI WAS ELEVATED
BY THE LEFT.
THE MEDIA COULDN'T GET ENOUGH OF
AVENATTI.
HE WENT FROM HUCKSTER
HARD-CHARGING PLANE'S LAWYER TO
NATIONWIDE BRAND.
HIS FACE WAS SUDDENLY PLASTERED
ALL OVER TV.
THIS PROFILE FROM "VANITY FAIR"
IS MY PERSONAL FAVORITE.
THERE HE IS, THE RACE CAR
DRIVING LAWYER WITH A SHAVED
HEAD AND WELL DEFINED CHEEKBONES
WHO LAUNCHED A THOUSAND HARD I
IMO JEEZ.
I DON'T THINK I CAN CONTINUE.
GOING ON TO TALK ABOUT SALACIOUS
RUMORS.
"I DON'T FAKE FAKE.
I DO MOISTURIZE.
AT ONE POINT LAST SPRING HE WAS
GETTING 100 TO 125 INTERVIEW
REQUESTS A DAY.
HE WAS SOON A FEATURED GUEST AT
GLITTERY EVENTS AS WELL.
MAYBE THEY CONFUSED HIM WITH THE
RAPPER PITBULL.
THEIR POLITICAL AND
ENTERTAINMENT MEDIA, THEY WORKED
OVERTIME TO SHOWCASE ALL THINGS
AVENATTI.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU SAW THIS COMING.
YOU ARE PUTTING A LOT OF CHIPS
ON WHAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN WITH
MICHAEL COHEN AND WHAT IT WOULD
MEAN FOR YOUR CASE BUT TODAY
YOUR STACK IS A LITTLE HIGHER.
MICHAEL AVENATTI, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
AVENATTI HAS BEEN GETTING FED
INFORMATION THAT'S MORE TRUE
THAN NOT.
>> WHAT HE'S DOING ON TV IS HIS
BUSINESS.
WE ARE GOING TO BRING IN A KEY
PLAYER FROM ALL OF THIS, MICHAEL
AVENATTI, HE SEES IT
DIFFERENTLY.
>> Laura: CURIOUSLY NEITHER
CUOMO NOR DON LEMON COVERED
AVENATTI'S ARREST LAST NIGHT BY
THE L.A.P.D. ON DOMESTIC ABUSE
CHARGES.
HUH, WONDER WHY.
LAST NIGHT ANDERSON COOPER DID
COVER MICHAEL AVENATTI'S
POST-PRISON PRESS CONFERENCE.
>> I APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU.
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI, RELEASED
FROM CUSTODY.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE THE
FOLLOW STORY.
MORE BREAKING NEWS IN THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION
POTENTIALLY DEVELOPMENT AS WE
WAIT FOR NEW MOVES FROM SPECIAL
CALLS FOR MUELLER.
>> Laura: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, I
MISSED IT.
IT WAS A DRIVE-BY MENTION.
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT TOPIC NOW.
GO, GO, GO.
FROM WEINSTEIN TO SHARPTON TO
LOUIS FARRAKHAN AND NOW
AVENATTI, THE DEMOCRATS OF THE
PATTERN OF ALIGNING THEMSELVES
WITH CD FIGURES EVEN IF IT MEANS
BETRAYING THE DEMOCRATS ESPOUSED
BETRAYING THE DEMOCRATS ESPOUSEV
BETRAYING THE DEMOCRATS ESPOUSEL
BETRAYING THE DEMOCRATS ESPOUSEE
BETRAYING THE DEMOCRATS ESPOUSES
BETRAYING THE DEMOCRATS ESPOUSET
BETRAYING THE DEMOCRATS ESPOUSEA
BETRAYING THE DEMOCRATS ESPOUSEW
BETRAYING THE DEMOCRATS ESPOUSEU
BETRAYING THE DEMOCRATS ESPOUSED
HAVE ADVANCED THEIR CAUSE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO SELL OUT BASIC
PRINCIPLES OF DECENCY AND
FAIRNESS IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
TAKE DOWN TRUMP AND FRANKLY
ANYONE CONNECTED TO HIM.
AT LEAST AVENATTI WAS FORTHRIGHT
IN HIS INTENTIONS.
>> I BELIEVE THAT OUR PARTY, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, MUST BE A
PARTY THAT FIGHTS FIRE WITH FIR
FIRE.
SO I SAY WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE
HIT HARDER.
>> Laura: ISN'T THAT WHAT THE
WOMAN WHO IS ACCUSING HIM IS
SAYING?
THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD'VE SEEN THE
FLAMEOUT COMING.
TRIED TO CHEAT HIS LAW PARTNER,
EVICTED FROM HIS OWN OFFICES,
WILLING TO CAST HIS LOT WITH A
SAD FIGURE LIKE DANIELS.
A GUY WHO STOOPED EVEN LAWYER TO
PEDDLE JULIE SWETNICK'S
DEFAMATORY CLAIMS AGAINST
KAVANAUGH.
AVENATTI WAS AN ARREST WAITING
TO HAPPEN HERE LAST MONTH SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CHAIR CHUCK
GRASSLEY MADE A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL TO BOTH AVENATTI AND
JULIE SWETNICK FOR MAKING FALSE
STATEMENTS TO CONGRESS.
THIS WAS SOME GUY THAT THE LEFT
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED AS A
PRESIDENTIAL CONTENDER FOR 2020.
FOR MONTHS, CLINTON ALUM ADAM
HAS BEEN SHUTTLING AVENATTI FROM
DEMOCRATIC PARTY EVENT TO
DEMOCRATIC PARTY EVENT AND
NURTURE FAMILIARIZE AVENATTI THE
WHOLE PROCESS OF RUNNING FOR THE
PRESIDENCY.
THE VERMONT DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ACTUALLY CANCELED AVENATTI'S
APPEARANCES THIS WEEKEND
FOLLOWING HIS ARREST.
WELL, IN A TWIST OF FATE, THE
MAN WHO URGED US TO BELIEVE THE
WOMEN MAKING WILD DECADES-OLD
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST KAVANAUGH
NOW HAS A CHANGE OF PERSPECTIVE.
>> I HAVE NEVER STRUCK A WOMAN.
I NEVER WILL STRIKE A WOMAN.
I HAVE BEEN AN ADVOCATE FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS MY ENTIRE CAREER
AND I'M GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
AN ADVOCATE.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE INTIMIDATED
FROM STOPPING WHAT I'M DOING.
>> Laura: I HAVE A QUESTION.
CAN YOU ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN'S
RIGHTS BEHIND BARS?
I GUESS THEY DO HAVE DESKS SET
UP IN PRISON.
HOWELL DEMOCRATS AND LIBERAL
WOMEN WHO EMBRACE THIS WOULD BE
TRUMP SLAYER REACT TO THIS?
HE IS INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN
GUILTY.
I SAID THAT LAST NIGHT BUT WILL
CNN GIVE EVEN A FRACTION OF THE